[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero yo vengo del mundo del fútbol es
ver las manos para que vamos vamos vamos
vamos vamos vamos vamos vamos vamos
bueno sé que hace poco me han escuchado
no
y que podría decir que yo le comentaba
medio que me muero de miedo haciendo
estas cosas
la verdad es que para mí esto es salir
de mi zona de confort porque soy
tartamudo para los que no sabían el niño
me decía ante perú
justo un amigo suyo una historia me está
diciendo que me decía jajaja jamón
quiero entonces
por eso era bueno que vamos a ver ahora
como bien decía la presentación
yo soy licencia del derecho así que
vamos a ver el valor del peritaje como
prueba en los procedimientos judiciales
les parece
nuevamente vamos a ver eso vamos a ver
conectando los puntos para mí esto ha
sido de gran aprendizaje aprender a
entender que todo tiene un porqué en la
vida y les quiero compartir una historia
muy personal por eso estaba más nervioso
porque si doy seminarios charlas pero
muy pocas veces hablamos de nuestra vida
personal bueno
tengo una confesión para hacerles
este año si sé algo de lo cual no estaba
muy orgulloso
es duro para mí decirles esto pero
hace 10 años decide estudiar derecho y
ser ahora
yo soy sí perdón adelantado
cómo sería el mundo sin abogados es
verdad pero no se preocupen yo mi título
lo tengo bien enmarcado bien bonito en
el baño de mi casa para que todo el
mundo entre y lo vea y tenga la
seguridad que yo no voy a ejercer y no
le voy a hacer daño a nadie pero les
quería contar esto porque es importante
porque esto ha sido parte de mí y me ha
ayudado a desenvolverme quien soy hoy
así que con las pocas habilidades
legales que me quedan les voy a armar un
pequeño caso con imputados todo para que
ustedes puedan dar su veredicto
esa foto ese niño regordete que ven ahí
es un niño lleno de sueños pero también
lleno de miedos
vamos a tomar un minuto de silencio para
el overol que reventó los kilitos
después estaba bien gordito
y la persona que está a mi derecha es mi
madre mi madre es
la personificación de todo lo que es
bueno en este mundo
es
ahora no sé nada
realmente la persona más importante en
mi vida y es el azul
la conocen cariñosamente mis amigos
ella ha sido
mi mentora en absolutamente todo y es la
persona por la cual yo tomo las
decisiones siempre pienso que haría mi
madre en este caso
bueno volviendo al mundo del derecho
yo estudié derecho por la misma razón
que el 43% de las personas que aplican a
derecho lo hacen
para escapar de las matemáticas aquí
está mi medio docente en realidad yo no
era malo en las matemáticas no soy malo
en los números pero había algo que yo no
sabía y hace poco me diagnosticaron yo
tengo ideas de tengo un síndrome de
déficit de atención hiperactividad la
hiperactividad la pueden ver porque no
paro de moverme acá y todas estas mentes
brillantes que ustedes ven también la
comparten
bueno los envidiosos
los envidiosos dirán que es pain pero
bueno yo también ahora esto
esto viene bien no todo es malo porque
nos hace personas super creativas con
capacidad de hiper enfoque pero
y no aptas para muchos procesos de
ecuaciones matemáticas y de orden
ya se imaginarán cuánto me ha costado
armar esta presentación
ahora yo ya había decidido estudiar
derecho tenía universidad aceptada en
chile- tenía donde me iba a quedar ya
estaba prácticamente en el avión pero mi
madre sufrió un problema de salud ha
detectado en el sistema pulmonar
entonces los recursos no daban y como mi
padre siempre brilló por su ausencia
tampoco le podía pedir a él así que
ese sueño
se estrelló y chile se quedó en su amigo
javier y yo me quedé estudiar acá
me quiere estudiar acá y a los 3 años me
di cuenta
no era para mí el derecho
había invertido tres años de mi vida en
estudiar algo en la cual yo no me veía
haciendo entonces me entró una crisis
existencial y como buen fin ayer como
todo adolescente que se respeta opté por
encerrarme en mi cuarto
escuchar a radiohead escribir canciones
melodramáticas lamentarme y decir porque
a mí porque yo tiene mi vida al tacho
estudiando esto entonces fue muy duro
un momento en esos que yo estaba
escuchando música a todo volumen
escuché a mi madre llorar
sin consuelo entonces le baje un poco la
música salí del cuarto a buscar qué
pasaba todos en mi casa estaban llorando
madre estaba pálida
y resulta que se había muerto mi hermano
tan solo 18 años y por fuera de lo común
extraordinario
y son estas cosas el ver el primer
verdadero golpe que recibí
era mi hermano no
un tipo guapo carismático canchero él
fue la persona que me impulsó a creer en
mí yo no podía leer en voz alta peor
hablar en público él me obligó a
declararme a mi primera chica
y él me obligó a cantar en público por
primera vez ese sonado una de mis
hobbies y pasiones
se había ido a tan solo 18 años sea
era algo inexplicable lacerante y yo
realmente
llegaron un odio a la vida a todos
porque
porque no voy a explicar bueno
si viene parte de confesiones número 2
esta no es tan grave como la del derecho
así que no se preocupen
que hice en este momento de mi vida
tenía una crisis existencial no tenía un
propósito acababa de sufrir la pérdida
muy grande entonces tomé una muy sabia
decisión que puede comprarme una botella
de tequila con mi amigo venia no
terminar me la
y
jugar a esto
quienes no conocen qué es esto se llama
ruleta rusa
ruleta rusa' exponerle una bala una
pistola las revueltas
y apostar que nada
en la cabeza
y bueno recuerdo
recuerdo todavía ese día
y recuerdo el frío del metal
mientras yo me lo apuntaba
el sudor pasando por mi frente la vida
pasando a través de mis ojos apretar el
gatillo
y gracias a dios
había perdido el juego
pasó ese momento y dije qué idiota y
egoísta
como voy a irme por ese lado
entonces al día siguiente fui al
cementerio y algo en mí se encendió
yo entendí
y la muerte de mi hermano no podía ser
en vano
no podía irse sin dejar algún mensaje y
él siempre peleó porque yo cree en mí
mismo
entonces ese para mí fue un punto
inflexión
y fue ahí cuando comencé a encaminar mi
vida no me gusta mi carrera no importa
si estudiando pero comencé a trabajar
repartía volantes se vendió ya pueden
dio como en las calles y absolutamente
todo y comencé a irme por el drama
comercial
y gracias a dios encontré
mi pasión pude organizar eventos
puede trabajar en proyectos muy
interesantes el contrato digo ahora
ayudo a emprendedores entonces la vida
se ponía bonita y también decidí
vencerle de miedo a los escenarios y
animarme a cantar en público me costó
muchísimo la primera vez está tan
nervioso que me tuvieron que pinchar
porque se me había tragado la garganta
conocí
a una mujer maravillosa que me ayudó a
vencer el miedo al compromiso
el miedo a ser amado y que me regale una
hermosa familia los hijos hermosos
bonito es decir
todo iba bien
hasta que de repente un día
el corazón de mi madre dejó de latir
yo realmente no sabía qué hacer en ese
momento no sabía cómo tomarlo
se envía muchísimo dolor sentía
muchísima pena
me sentía prácticamente solo
y dos meses después alguien mi familia
decidió también jugar ruleta rusa
pero esta vez ganó
fue mi padre
decidió quitarse la vida
entonces como diría mi papá es en ese
momento que llovía sobre mojado
ahora porque les cuento esto la verdad
no es el ánimo de hacer todo un drama de
la vida sino que eran dos momentos
distintos a los 19
yo no tenía un propósito no sabía que
quería hacer con mi vida
no tenía mayor fuente de inspiración
y esto a mis 25
realmente el golpe más duro de la vida
pero era mi madre perder a mi padre de
esa manera
la verdad es que también
me despierta todavía por las noches su
imagen en la autopsia
ese momento te sientes solo si bien yo
tenía una esposa hijos ellos estaban
ellos dependían de mí
no podía ir a mi casa a llorar
entonces yo lloraba en la ducha
y ahora mi auto y recuerdo un día
particular donde estaba en mi auto
realmente no daba más
sentí el cambio de paradigma en mi deje
de preguntarme por qué porque a mí de
lamentarme
y dije
enséñame a ver para qué cómo puedo tomar
esta desgracia porque si era así y
convertirlo en una oportunidad
enseña a ver el mensaje detrás de esto
le pedí al viejo árbol
ustedes lo pueden llamar como quieran
que me guíe
en este proceso que para mí era de la
durísimo
pero a diferencia de los 19 yo contaba
con tres armas que eso es lo que les
quiero dejar con
y me han ayudado muchísimo
tener la capacidad de resiliencia desde
la capacidad de seguir adelante con la
vida
la primera es introspección
a los 19 yo no sabía quién era no sabía
para qué había venido este mundo no
sabía cuáles eran mis debilidades y
fortalezas
yo a los 25 ya había hecho un trabajo
introspección sabía para que había
venido sabía dónde tenía que apuntar mi
carrera sabía que yo con la pena no
puedo lidiar
entonces cuando falleció mi madre yo a
los dos días me fui a hacer un curso de
coaching que tenía agendado porque sabía
que no me podía quedar ahí porque corrió
el riesgo de otra vez sumergirme en la
pena
entonces esa introspección te ayuda a
buscar un propósito porque tú ya sabes
quién eres entonces
pesar más absolutamente todo para volver
a armarlo
qué traumas has tenido en la niñez como
te han criado que karma está trayendo
todo esto
lo llevas con un propósito
a donde quiero ir que quiero hacer
yo encontré
un propósito que para mí es dar
que lo heredé de mi madre como todas las
cosas buenas que he tenido y eso es lo
que me hace feliz a mí no me mueve la
plata no me mueve el éxito
más muchas veces ni duerme crítica como
no me mueve la plata entonces pero a mí
me mueve esto
en el velorio de mi madre yo pude ver
como su propósito rebalsaba todo
no que había espacio para las flores
porque había espacios para la ayuda de
los amigos
y en cambio con mi padre ni siquiera lo
pude velar y él seguramente también tomó
esa decisión
porque no tenía un propósito
porque había perdido su propósito
su propósito es
para lo que eres bueno
los dones que has tenido
tu trabajo tienes que encontrar ese
punto medio su razón de ser lo que te
mueve como simon tiene que diría es tu
golden shirt es el por qué hacemos las
cosas
y tercero y no menos importante es la
gratitud
la gratitud está directamente
relacionada con la felicidad pero no te
hablo de una gratitud ñoña
para la otra mejilla de decirle gracias
a las personas te hablo de que realmente
cambies de paradigma y veas todo como
una oportunidad porque están regalando
una segunda chance
porque todo lo que te pasa en esta vida
es por tu bien hay un plan de arriba y
tú tienes que aprender a conectar los
puntos y saber si yo me hubiese ido a
chile probablemente hoy sería un abogado
mediocre miserable porque si no me queda
otra que estudiar todos mis recursos ahí
entonces
aprendí a conectar esos puntos y
agradecer también el pasado
muchas veces con los amigos decían oye
qué época más dura
y años
pero al final ese pedido que le hice al
de arriba lo llegué a entender bien
ya me conocía muy bien y sabía que si no
me pegaba muy duro si no me pegaba
pronto yo no iba a entender la lección
entonces esos dos meses entre el que se
muere mi madre y se muere mi padre me
sirvieron para hacer lo que marketing
llamamos un benchmark es un comparativo
la vida me estaba diciendo puedes seguir
el camino de tu padre puedes ir
haciéndole daño a la gente puedes ir
rompiendo tus relaciones
puedes ir recepcionando a tus hijos y
terminar así o puedes tomar el camino de
tu madre
yo reconozco y agradezco a la vida hice
que el 80% de las cosas buenas que tengo
no son mérito mío
son karma de mi vieja
entonces yo entiendo eso
quiero que la mejor herencia que yo
tenga preciosidad
curar mi karma y dejarles lo que llamado
entonces son estos tres factores
que los van a ayudar me han ayudado
a ver la vida de otra manera
y siempre a proponer a vencer los miedos
como esta y entonces yo quiero que se
nos quede este mensaje a todos
quiero agradecerles de todo corazón
porque
y estoy seguro que para mí esto ha sido
más gratificante que para ustedes quiero
invitarlos a que hoy cierran los ojos
hagan un ejercicio de gratitud
y en unidades que el estado la vida
todo lo bueno que tiene
haga una lista
van a ver se los prometo y hacen de esto
un hábito
como va a ir cambiando el paradigma
[Aplausos]
[Música]